okay so april has a stacked month with
morbius fantastic beasts and sonic 2.
the sequel to 2020 sonic the hedgehog is
an absolutely brilliant movie and though
i haven't seen fantastic beasts yet it's
going to be difficult to match just how
fun this is throughout this video we're
going to be going through the whole
movie and breaking it down but because
of this there will be heavy spoilers if
you enjoy then please smash the thumbs
up button and don't forget to subscribe
for the channel where we get sonic till
we vomit terrible pun one of the worst
but i appreciate you bearing with me now
let's get into sonic 2. now sonic 2
continues on from the first film with dr
robotnik still stuck on the mushroom
plane that first appeared in sonic and
knuckles mushroom hill zone hasn't made
him mushroom chill though and he's
desperate to get back to earth in a
funny sequence which jim carrey eats up
he uses his genius to create traps for
the people coming to save him and he
even has a wilson reference as he makes
an agent stone figure out of a stone see
i knew he cared for him deep down now
it's not long before knuckles crew turns
up and they're taken out by robotnik
leaving just the red-headed rascal
behind he's the last of his kind the
echidna who had the master emerald and
used it to fight wars before it was
stolen by longclaw's tribe they believed
it was too powerful for anyone to bear
and there's actually a lot of laws
surrounding it in the games the master
emerald was located on angel island and
knuckles crew went on to harness it for
themselves before declining in power to
the point that their numbers dwindled
now we may see the pure chaos and
further backstory of the master emerald
from the games as we push into sonic
adventure storylines but that's for
later down the line now the movie
adapted the games well as sonic 3 saw
defeated robotnik trick knuckles into
the idea that sonic and tails were gonna
steal the emerald but in reality he
wanted it for himself to power his death
egg once more the film does a superb job
of condensing sonic 2 3 and even sonic
and knuckles a classic that saw the blue
streak continue his run of great games
before it all kind of went to crap
around the time mario 64 drop it really
shows why it's important to pay
attention to the games that paved the
way and it's a complete opposite to halo
which had the tv show creators dropping
in interviews that they completely
ignored the games that show has gone
down worse than the sega vr and sonic 2
is a great example of how to do it right
now the story changes the mythos of the
chaos emeralds quite heavily but it
works very well and fits in nicely with
the tales they're telling now on the
opposite side of the robotnik's
storyline we have sonic who's really
taken to his life of being a hero he
stops robbers from taking a bank truck
in chaotic fashion always hits the
thumbs up button and has clearly watched
way more movies than i have he says he's
the hero they need and deserve which of
course riffs on the dark knight and the
persona and charm of sonic is hammered
home expertly throughout the film sonic
was always supposed to be the cool
auntie mario and it works really well
here providing us with a lot of
references to other films unfortunately
for him his double life is discovered by
tom and maddie and this happens in a
hilarious scene that reminded me a lot
of the schemes that you saw in home
alone he created a decoy that looks like
sonic the legendary ms paint drawing of
the hero and it's the part that had me
laughing the hardest yes i fought jokes
schwartz delivered them well he dropped
them really well now his adoptive
parents head off to rachel's wedding and
we see sonic take part in a hilarious
sequence of living it up home alone with
references to risky business complete
with his shirt and glasses it's also
something i certainly did not expect
with a nod to voice actor ben schwartz's
role of john ralphio and parks and rec
who elaborately says it's the worst now
it's not long before we get to see
robotnik and knuckles arrive with tails
on the way the rivalry really adds some
dynamics to the film and we get some
great shots of sonic and knuckles
fighting showing just how better the
ladder is he was always the cool
character and casting idris alba was
such an inspired choice as he's also one
of the suavest dudes in hollywood right
now he demands to know exactly where the
master emerald is which of course sonic
is completely oblivious over teaming up
with tails we also get the voice of
colleen o'shagnasi who has been playing
the character for several years unlike
the mario movie sonic's producers took a
chance on using a true voice actor and
it worked expertly well making me wish
that more studios did this now we get a
hint of the wider galaxy as tails
explains that he's been watching sonic
ever since the energy blast from the
last movie during the escape we see
knuckles smash through the splash
shields truck which was a level in sonic
4. now it turns out the master emerald
is not a myth like sonic thought and we
learned that he was actually wanted by
longclaw to become its next guardian
this is told to us in hologram and it
gave me a lot of dural vibes later on in
the movie we see how it was kept in a
secret temple and this is a change up
from the games in those it was on angel
island and this briefly appeared on
earth during the sonic x anime and comic
series however this could simply be the
movie's version of the island which was
protected by knuckles interestingly tom
could also be a stand-in for christopher
thorndike who did appear in that series
how else elsewhere knuckles and robotnik
read an accord and agent stone is called
into action once more in any touch the
coffee shop is named the mean bean which
is of course a reference to the game
namely dr robotnik's mean bean machine
the doc also receives his eggmobile
which debuted in the original mega drive
game yes mega drive or genesis if yet in
america which i feel so i'm just kidding
i like america anyway inside the mean
bean is also the trademark eggman logo
later in the lab are also some different
costume stone was pondering for his
employer including a creepy made outfit
and also take on negan eggman's outfit
from sonic rush tales and sonic track
down the first clue to siberia and after
a dance-off bro they head back out to
the temple which features a compass to
the master emerald however they are
attacked by robotnik and nichols along
with the doctor's machines which include
bee-like creatures from the first game
now while they're on kidnapped animals
inside robotnik hints at his desire to
enslave people when he says he wants to
control all of humanity using the
emerald sonic escapes with tails who
flies off and he uses a piece of metal
to snowboard which is akin to the sonic
adventure 2 opening level which featured
the greatest game song of all time
outside of snakey there now it's here we
learn how knuckles and sonic both became
the last of their respective tribes and
that they're not so different you and i
both are of course orphans of an ancient
feud and the pair just want to keep the
master emerald safe however despite
knuckles almost siding with him sonic
and tails end up on the back foot again
and they end up in hawaii notes here
that the movie does throw out quite a
bit as we get the the subplot of
rachel's wedding which is quite weak to
me the rest of the movie did a bang-up
job of adapting that albeit convoluted
sonic history and the fact tom's
ringtone is the green hill zone theme is
great but yeah this just kind of bogs it
down a bit now with sonic and tails
arriving there it's quickly revealed
that everyone at the wedding are gun
agents aka guardian units of nations
tales and sonic are captured and sent to
a chopper which is a reference to sonic
adventure 2's opening they're taken by
the gun commander in the games who looks
just like the olive garden enthusiast
who's in control here nice bit of
product placement there now the pair are
freed and rachel gets a revenge on her
catfish knuckles and robotnik find the
temple and make their way into the main
chamber sonic is forced to overcome his
fear of water as during the fishing
scene he says he can't swim and has to
speed over it it reminded me a lot of
elsa trying to cross the scene frozen
too however in the games he can't swim
underwater forever and has to use oxygen
bubbles to keep going just like he did
before being saved by knuckles robotnik
reveals his true motivations to seal the
emerald for himself and hilariously
taunts knuckles as the place falls apart
leaving him and sonic having to team up
to take him down i think the
relationship between the pair works
really well and tails arrives in his
trademark biplane and again tails just
looks great with those goggles back in
green hills robotnik creates a gigantic
mecha robotnik with a head that looks
like the death egg that appeared in the
games stone also pulls out a manual that
looks like the mega drive genesis
booklet and i was pleased at just how
easter egg heavy that the movie became
this machine is actually also ripping on
the great eggman robo from sonic and
knuckles as the rockets and flamethrower
are very similar the trio is a team have
been a scenic kind of sonic heroes where
you could drop a group attack using a
number of characters and seriously how
good were sonic heroes yeah let me let
me know in the comments below a sonic
manages to retrieve the emerald but it
shatters revealing the chaos ones inside
which in the games were used as
collectibles these helped to charge
sonic up until he becomes supersonic
which in the games was unlocked after
reaching a certain milestone of
collecting it's a super cool scene as
sonic seems to have ascended but he uses
his powers to create a chili dog his
iconic favorite food robotnik is
defeated but later is nowhere to be
found potentially teasing his return in
a future sequel a jim carrey has stated
that he wants to take a break from
acting for a while so they might even
bring in a different villain and if he
decides to come back get him in a movie
after that knuckles ends up joining
sonic and tales which begins the
formation of team sonic that appeared in
sonic heroes they then swear to protect
the master emerald from all who would
abuse it and we get a post credit scene
which is incredibly intriguing as the
gun agents learn of project shadow in
the game's project shadow or shadow of
the hedgehog was created by the
grandfather of robotnik who we learned
was gerald robotnik gerald intended to
save his granddaughter maria from an
illness and he created the mysterious
hedgehog or hedgehog as i like to call
him look how bloody edge he is but this
edginess was deemed dangerous and after
shadow was seen as a potential threat he
was put on ice in sonic adventure 2
robotnik learns of this and he wants to
use him to stop sonic and take over the
world now i do think that with kerry
stepping back that they might reframe
stuff slightly and potentially we could
just get shadow as the main antagonist
hopefully they back up the money truck
and give kerry more golden rings than
sonic has after your boy kevin spoilers
plays the game on easy mode and of
course love to have him back sonic 2 was
a blast from beginning to end and
despite the weird catfish revenge of
rachel it delved deep into the law of
sonic and handled two additional
characters expertly whilst retaining the
magic of the first i hope they can carry
on the home run for a third film and i
truly think that this was better than
the first one due to the game's story
adaptation and less humans as i
mentioned they could potentially go
there with shadow and i think the studio
and creative team are probably realizing
more and more that these characters can
stand on their own two feet without the
need for the humans either way yeah i
know i'm nitpicking there but great
second movie and we're giving it an 8
out of 10. i'd of course love to hear
your thoughts so make sure you comment
below and let me know we are in a
competition right now giving away three
copies of spider-man noway home on the
15th of april and all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
breakdown and moonlight which will be
linked on screen right now the second
episode is now out we're here to talk
about it so definitely go check it out
right after this without the way thanks
for sticking through the video i've been
poor i'll see you next time take care
peace